colère et incompréhension pour ces
centaines de manifestants venus
protester contre leur confinement
général visant à faire face à la
résurgence de la pandémie la population
israélienne estime le gouvernement
incapable de gérer l'épidémie est un
coupable semble tout désigné
le premier ministre benyamin nétanyahou
aujourd'hui il y ait eu un rassemblement
c'est la dernière chance d'arrêter un
confinement injustifiée qui ne fait que
nuire à la population
il ya des médecins et des gens qui se
trouvent en première ligne dans la lutte
contre le coronavirus qui vont parler et
présenter des faits montrant qu'il n'y a
pas de logique et pas de justification
pour revenir à un confinement
au contraire le confinement est néfaste
à la population c'est complètement
inacceptable
en mars nous étions nombreux à ne pas
savoir ce qui se passait et nous avons
écouté le gouvernement
désormais il est juste évident qu'il
n'ya aucune logique derrière le
confinement a pas rendre les gens
déprimés bloquées dans leurs maisons
faire des choses mauvaises pour leur
santé c'est ce que le gouvernement nous
dit de faire depuis le début de la crise
sanitaire la plus grande de l'histoire
et nous en avons véritablement assez de
tout ça un ras-le-bol qui s'explique par
les mesures drastiques prises par le
gouvernement pour les trois prochaines
semaines à compter de ce vendredi 14
heures heure locale
les israéliens auront interdiction de se
rendre à plus de 500 mètres de chez eux
hormis pour aller faire leurs courses à
la pharmacie ou au travail s'il s'agit
d'une profession jugée essentielle
le tout dans une période particulière en
effet les synagogues sont en général
remplis lors des deux jours de roches et
shana et surtout de yom kippour
mais cette année les fidèles iront prier
dans les synagogues en fonction de la
taille de l'édifice et pour la première
fois de son histoire la grande synagogue
de jérusalem n'accueillera pas les
célébrations du nouvel an juif
en raison des restrictions dues à
l'épidémie ces deux derniers jours nous
avons assisté à une autre augmentation
alarmante de la mortalité et à
l'augmentation continue du nombre de
patients gravement malades
c'est pourquoi j'ai eu une longue
conversation aujourd'hui avec le
ministre de la santé mme yuli edelstein
avec le chef de projet le professeur
rosny gamme so et d'autres experts
argentins aimar maintenant j'estime qu'à
la lumière de cette conversation
dans cette situation de mortalité et
comme de nombreux experts l'ont
recommandé comme nous l'avons dit n'être
pas d'autre choix que de retirer les
directrices des lignes directrices que
le chef du gouvernement n'hésitera pas à
durcir si nécessaire des mesures de
confinement perçue comme un coup de
massue par une partie de la population
pays de 9 millions d'habitants
israël a officiellement enregistré plus
de 172 milles 4 2 coronavirus pour mille
cent soixante trois décès plus
inquiétant l'état hébreu le pays qui a
recensé le plus fort taux de
contamination ces deux dernières
semaines